jacques mézard le président du groupe
rdse au sénat est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous donc pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse
représenter ce soir par jean louis
prévost perrine tarneaud nous rejoindra
bien sûr en fin d'émission pour évoquer
notamment l'un des grands combats des
radicaux jacques mézard la laïcité quand
on débat à nouveau aujourd'hui
régulièrement mais avant d'évoquer
notamment la situation en grèce le vote
aujourd'hui de la loi macron ultime
recours donc à l'article 49-3 par manuel
valls qui affirme que c'est un coup de
jeune pour l'économie est ce que vous
partager son enthousiasme je crois que
c'est d'abord un message pense pas
qu'ils aient des mesures qui vont
révolutionner le fonctionnement de la
vie économique du pays mais c'est
clairement un message politique adressé
non seulement aux élus à la majorité
présidentielle mais à l'ensemble des
français
la loi macro quel message le message
qu'il est nécessaire de de libéraliser
de donner plus de liberté aux fonctions
de fonctionnement de notre économie
je crois que c'est le message qui a été
d'ailleurs assez entendu au sénat mais
qu'est ce que traduit suffisamment dans
les faits concrètement non selon vous
non non non parce que notre pays a
besoin d'avoir moins de contraintes
moins de contraintes ce n'est pas
fragilisé
ceux qui sont les plus
fragile ce n'est pas à enlever des
droits aux salariés mais c'est permettre
à l'économie de travailler dans de
meilleures conditions est ce que vous
rejoignez par exemple l'opposition de
droite jacques mézard qui considère qui
est effectivement il manque dans ce
texte des mesures pour desserrer marché
du travail par exemple
oui je lui ai d'ailleurs dit mais ça je
crois qu'il faut être très prudent parce
que notre pays est quand même dans une
situation où faire bouger les choses à
ce niveau là est très difficile quel que
soit le gouvernement et je dis que nous
avons besoin de moins de contraintes de
moins de normes mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il faut laisser faire tout et
n'importe quoi à ceux qui ont pouvoir et
en particulier le pouvoir économique
mais on voit bien quand on parle à des
chefs d'entreprises de petite entreprise
de moyennes entreprises sur le terrain
qu'ils n'en peuvent plus d'être étouffée
par trop de contraintes administratives
et cela les empêchera pas cité cette
cote de travail dont vous parlez
il ya pas que le code du travail
allemand il y a le code du travail à
l'environnement il ya tout un tas de
contraintes dans tous les secteurs et
avec la meilleure volonté du monde
les parlementaires en rajoute souvent
nous le vivons est hélas nous avons
aussi à prendre conscience du fait qu'il
faut faire moins de loin pour mieux les
appliquer alors que j'ai entreprise ils
le disent les deux mesures effet le plus
immédiat souligne encore manuel valls et
le travail le dimanche et l'ouverture de
lignes d'autocars parce que pour les
approuver et qu'est ce que vous en
espérez vous coûte nous ne devons pas
considérer
majoritairement ce groupe que la
question du travail du dimanche était
quelque chose qui allait révolutionner
d'autant qu'il ya beaucoup de français
déjà qu'ils travaillent le dimanche
et que se battent pour savoir si les
commerces vont pouvoir ouvrir un plus de
dimanche n'est quand même pas une
révolution idéologique lignes d'autocars
c'est un autre dossier parce que il
oh que nous considérions que dans en
particulier dans les territoires ruraux
que je représente souvent et en
particulier il ya une crainte il ya une
crainte c'est que ce message ce soit en
ferme les lignes de train on sait bien
que c'est difficile de faire fonctionner
arrivera vous avez entendu le
gouvernement se réserve cette
possibilité mais après les régionales
oui moi je ne doutais pas de l'objectif
final mais là il faudrait il faut être
très prudent ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
rien bouger mais ça veut dire que il
faut que nous conservions un certain
nombre de lignes ferroviaires qui sont
indispensables sur nos territoires sont
déficitaires et utilisé par très peu de
voyageurs avec des rames à moitié vide
ou aux trois quarts vide jacques mézard
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut les
conserver tout ça veut dire que dans un
pays si on n'a pas une une politique
d'aménagement du territoire une
politique qui permet justement 20 dans
certains territoires et dans certains
cas de conserver un certain nombre de
moyens de transport ou de vie qui sont
déficitaires
il vient dans ce cas là il vaut mieux
dire ceux qui vivent des ménages est bon
alors que là aussi il faut du bon sens
il faut de l'équilibré vers des points
sur la loi macron à propos du passage en
force avec l'article 49-3 qu'est ce que
ça révèle selon vous de l'état du ps est
de la majorité à laquelle vous
appartenez
oui même si je suis souvent critique ça
révèle très simplement que les lignes de
fracture fondamentale traverse les deux
partis principaux le parti socialiste et
les républicains et qu'on voit bien que
gouverner dans ces conditions là et
c'est un des problèmes de la vème
république
la ville vit une crise c'est extrêmement
difficile parce que le gouvernement en
place est obligé de tenir compte de
positions de parlementaires qui sont
manifestement pas en phase avec le
gouvernement alors qu'ils sont les élus
de ce parti dominant quelle conséquence
vous en tirer pour l'avenir
pour l'avenir je pense que
je souhaite pour la vraie distribution
des cartes politiques
je le souhaite vivement parce qu'avec
celui qui vaut mieux que ceux qui ont
des conceptions assez proches sur des
problèmes fondamentaux que ce soit la
construction de l'europe que ce soit
l'économie
que ce soit les institutions travaillent
ensemble plutôt que d'être opposé par le
système à leurs revenus d'enseignement
radical de gauche vous seriez prêt à
faire alliance avec qui dans ce contexte
là que c'est celui que vous définissez
mais il s'agit pas de donner des noms et
non parce que ça n'a pas ça n'a pas de
sens de donner le nom je crois que ça
veut dire très simplement qu'il faut
voir et dans ce parti par exemple
écouter longue partie
il ya une bonne partie du parti
socialiste il ya les radicaux de gauche
il peut y avoir des centristes il peut y
avoir des républicains moi je crois que
la france est dans une telle situation
aujourd'hui comme nombre de pays qu'il
faut essayer de surmonter dans certains
cas des clivages qui sont artificiels
c'est pas facile à dire c'est pas facile
à assumer
parce que la tranquillité des deux
grands partis c'est de continuer à être
l'un après l'autre au gouvernement mais
aujourd'hui le système de l'élection
présidentielle le quinquennat que j'ai
combattu un abouti
malheureusement à une situation
politique qui n'est pas très heureuse et
qui favorise la montée des extrêmes bon
d'accord alors justement vous avez cité
l'europe comme ligne de fracture au sein
des deux grands partis que vous avez
cité le parti socialiste et puis les
républicains alors qu'on attend donc les
réformes les contreparties précise
alexis tsipras ça une nouvelle aide
européenne à la grèce quel regard est ce
que vous vous portez sur ce premier
ministre grec qui qui joue avec les
nerfs de ses partenaires et créanciers
je pense qu'il y à une surmédiatisation
ce que l'on a vu dimanche soir avec des
chaînes en continu n'arrêtant pas de
parler de du premier ministre grec de ce
qu'il avait fait non c'est normal
c'était la vienne malgré soit considéré
qu' ils ont célébré les médias ont
célébré avec celle ci que je considère
que on donne à cet événement un poids
qui dans l'avenir je le pense démontrera
que c'est quand même de la
surmédiatisation
ceci étant on peut le comprendre
je crois aussi que le premier ministre
cipra se joue il joue parce qu'il a pris
des engagements avec ses concitoyens
qu'il se rend compte que ces engagements
sont extrêmement difficile à tenir et
que à la fois le référendum avait pour
but de rassurer ses concitoyens et de
les regrouper autour de lui sur les
thèmes qui lui sont chers mais en même
temps aussi
nous voyons aujourd'hui qu'il est obligé
mais à ne faire des progrès et il faut
que je continue à chercher un conte
premier avec quelqu'un qui joue t moi je
ne crois pas que l'on puisse faire tout
et n'importe quoi
je les dis hier dans la discussion
générale il faut de la solidarité mais à
condition qu'elle soit accompagnée de
fermeté nous ne pouvons pas accepter par
rapport à la grèce ce que l'on ne fait
pas vis-à-vis à d'autres pays je pense
au portugal qui règle
rubis sur l'ongle ses engagements
financiers et donc dans ces conditions
moi je crois que il y aura une sortie
positive non pas de l'euro mais qu'il y
aura une solution qui sera trouvée parce
que la grèce a plus à perdre à sortir de
l'euro la question de l'union européenne
ne se pose pas parce qu'ils sortiront
pas de l'union européenne mais on va
plus à perdre à sortir de l'euro qu'à
trouver à faire des propositions
raisonnables
on parle souvent de ce qui se passe en
grèce sur les retraites sur le fait que
le clergé ne payent pas l'impôt que les
armateurs may pas grand chose ils ont
manifestement un certain nombre de
propositions sérieuses à faire le la
moyenne médiane aujourd'hui des
retraites en grèce ces 900 euros comme
en allemagne et en france on est à 1200
euros
je n'entends pas beaucoup un de ceux qui
sont les zélateurs de monsieur sy brasse
en france se plaindre des retraites par
exemple dans le monde agricole en france
qui sont souvent au dessous de 700 euros
chacun assume des difficultés de cette
année va t on les trouve notamment aux
extrêmes oui très clairement mais le
gouvernement de monsieur sy brasse il ya
un représentant d'un parti souverainiste
très très à droite
donc c'est la conjonction d'un certain
nombre de deux partis qui représentent
effectivement des courants très
différents mais qui sont donc moyen de
rapprochement c'est le populisme
il ya aussi dans les proches monsieur
qui brassent un certain nombre d'anciens
conseillers de gouvernement anciens qui
sont aujourd'hui décrié gouvernement
socialiste riz alors le couple
franco-allemand était très exposée
durant cette crise
et vous vous écoutez jacques mézard on
se dit que vous pensez peut-être plus du
côté de mettre en évidence dans gala
merkel que de la volonté de conciliation
de françois hollande
est ce que je me trompe bon je crois je
crois que les les deux il est nécessaire
vis-à-vis de la grèce d'avoir un message
de fermeté en disant il ya des choses
qui ne sont pas acceptables il faut pas
non plus les victimiser la grèce donc je
crois que le couple allemand
chacun joue le trump a finalement chacun
joue sa partition et les deux sont
attachés à la construction européenne
alors il la voit peut-être pas
exactement de la même manière mais je
crois d'ailleurs que la complémentarité
de ces deux positions à condition
qu'elles ne s'opposent pas mais qu'elle
soit complémentaire est utile il faut
faire comprendre
c'était le cas je crois juste un oui je
crois qu'il faut faire comprendre à la
grèce qui a un seuil à un niveau au delà
duquel
les autres pays ni renta et je pense je
suis peut-être optimiste que le
gouvernement grec sera obligé d'entendre
ce message
ensuite grâce à dans les heures qui
viennent un mot sur un homme d'affaires
qui kiffent fumantes du parti radical de
gauche même candidats d'autres partis et
bernard tapie
jacques mézard rien ne l'arrête il veut
réclamer maintenant un milliard d'euros
à l'état plus les intérêts sur 20 ans
dans la sphère adidas est ce qu il a
raison de tenter le coup ok je suis
étonné que vous ne posiez pas la
question sur le scandale de panama ya
125 ans sur l'affairé stavisky avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
contrairement à vous je n'ai jamais eu
l'occasion de discuter avec monsieur
tapie il a été dans le parti radical de
gauche ici même il y a trois ou quatre
ans j'ai été interrogé sur un éventuel
mans à un éventuel retour de monsieur
tapie dans le parti et j'ai dit que
s'ils y rentrer je partirai donc je n'ai
pas d'autres commentaires
donc un commentaire si on met de côté ce
son étiquette politique même ancien je
le fais je n'ai jamais en tout cas
accepter personnellement le mélange de
l'affairisme et de la politique sd sans
selon vous de sa part de réclamer cette
somme colossale sachant qu'il avait déjà
reçu ce chèque de plus de 15 millions
d'euros de bercy 4 rien et descend dans
le mélange de l'affairisme et de la
politique
voilà c'est dit avec force pas de
mélange de politique et d'affairisme à
propos de bernard tapie
on poursuit cette émission jacques
mézard avec jean louis prévost de l'
agence france-presse qui va nous
rejoindre et nous allons explorer le
monde mystérieux et opaque des zones
ministre d autorité administrative
indépendante puisque vous avez vous une
commission d' enquête sur ces
commissions qui coûte cher et dont
l'utilité reste à démontrer avant de
vous interroger donc premiers éléments
de compréhension et d'interrogations
avec faustine saint geniès vous
connaissez sans doute l'autorité des
marchés financiers le csa ou encore la
cnil mais connaissez-vous la fld ou le
hpe rs des autorités administratives
indépendantes comme celle ci il en
existe une quarantaine en france mais à
quoi servent tél c'est l'une des
questions que pose la commission d'
enquête sur ce sujet au sénat
et en avril dernier à la demande des
radicaux de gauche le moment est
probablement venu de s'intéresser enfin
de se poser la question est ce que il
faut continuer à multiplier les hôtes
les hautes autorités qu'est ce que ça
veut dire à la fois en terme de la
location des finances publiques et
qu'est ce que ça veut dire aussi en
terme de pouvoir qui qui gouverne
objectif donc défricher cet amas
d'autorité en tous genres certaines
disposent de moyens financiers propres
certaines peuvent exercer des sanctions
la commission met donc des auditions
tous azimuts mais à chaque fois les
intéressés répondent la même chose
l'initiative des sénateurs est bonne
mais pas question a priori deux touchera
leur entité indispensable selon eux les
questions qui m'ont été posées n'était
nullement une remise en cause du rôle du
csa en tant qu autorité administrative
indépendante
ce débat nous a permis d'avoir un
échange et sur les fondements de
l'institution et sur son actualité
récente difficile de faire bouger les
lignes sur ce thème véritable serpent de
mer
en 2010 déjà un rapport parlementaire et
peint glay ces autorités administratives
indépendantes son auteur le député
socialiste rené dosière
toutes sont maintenant soumises à un
contrôle et aux normes budgétaires qui
s'applique d'administration ce qui n'est
pas le cas avant mais si certaines de
ces recommandations ont été prises en
compte
cela reste encore très insuffisant à son
goût il y a un certain nombre
d'autorités qui n'ont plus d'utilité qui
pourraient disparaître
je crois qu'il faut que les parlements
regarde de beaucoup plus près
le fonctionnement l'activité de ses
autorités indépendantes pour pouvoir
à ce moment-là modifier les règles voire
faire disparaître ou regroupées celles
qui ont besoin de se retrouver avec
d'autres davantage de contrôle par le
parlement lui-même une piste qui
pourrait être reprise par les sénateurs
reste à savoir si ce nouveau rapport
sera suivi d'effets alors on a envie
d'en savoir plus sur ces administrations
en face et ses organismes avec vous jean
luc prévost vos questions à jacques
mézard qui sont elles les quelques
fautes 1 éliminé prioritairement on sûr
monsieur arue fameuse autorité
administrative indépendante alors à
votre avis est-ce qu'elles sont aussi
trop nombreuses lesquels vous voudriez
supprimés on n'est pas à la liste des
suppressions
j'évolue qu'il y ait une commission d'
enquête du sénat pour que nous puissions
faire véritablement le point sur ces
autorités administratives indépendantes
aujourd'hui il y en a 40 de la première
a été créée en 1979 ça fait donc
pratiquement une par an et si ça
continue on n'aura plus assez de
conseiller l'état de conseiller à la
cour des comptes ou à la cour de
cassation pour remplir les collèges de
ces autorités administratives
indépendantes parce qu'il ya quand même
souvent les mêmes personnes ou en tout
cas le même type de personne qui y
siègent
quarante deux c'est beaucoup c'est
l'expression du délitement du pouvoir de
l'état et moi républicain assez jacobins
je le concède
je considère que ce n'est pas une bonne
chose est que là dedans il ya de tout
comme autorité administrative
indépendante avec des moyens de
fonctionnement extrêmement différent des
moyens financiers extrêmement différent
et certaines qui ont pris au cours de
ces dernières années un pouvoir
considérable on voit aujourd'hui les
problèmes du csa je ne reviendrai pas là
dessus on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
d'ici le mois de septembre
l'autorité de la concurrence à laquelle
la loi macron donne encore plus de
pouvoir de son président nous a expliqué
il veut plus de moyens plus de pouvoir
lui aussi bailly live amis
un milliard d' euros damende qui peut en
faire autant en france même pas mal
c'est et du consommateur c'est contre
les ententes entre les médias au siège
dans ces autorités administratives dite
indépendante et c'est ça c'est une
question de fond est alors vous pensez
que ce sont des représentants des
industries ou des distributions qui
siège à la haute autorité de la
concurrence il devrait écouter vous
lirez pas ce que je vais pas aujourd'hui
déflorer les conclusions d'un rapport
qui est en cours mais il suffit de voir
qui siègent dans les collèges pour se
poser un certain nombre de questions il
ya des autorités administratives
indépendantes qui sont utiles et dont le
statut ne peut pas être ne doit pas être
remise en cause je pense au défenseur
des droits
je pense à la cnidh ensuite les regrets
les regroupements c'est autre chose mais
nous ne disons pas qu'il faut supprimer
toutes les autorités administratives
indépendantes
nous disons il y en a trop on en crée en
moyenne une par an c'est vraiment le
délitement du pouvoir de l'état et dans
la composition des collèges de ces
autorités administratives indépendantes
on voit quand même pratiquement toujours
mais c'est le législateur qui en a
décidé donc nous sommes responsables les
moteurs on voit des conseillers d'état
on voit des conseillers des membres de
la cour des comptes on voit un des
membres de la cour de cassation et des
parlementaires
c'est très variable souviens il y en a
apparemment a priori personnalités
éminentes met tout sur le même moule bon
et avec la même origine je dis pas qu'il
ya partout la promotion voltaire de
l'ena m'enfin avait un lien quand même
pas mal vous parlez des rémunérations il
ya de tout dans il y en a qui font ce
travail pratiquement bénévolement
ça dépend des autorités administratives
à nantes et il y en a qui ont des
revenus extrêmement important ceci étant
dans certains secteurs on vous dira
qu'il faut qu'ils aient des revenus
importants sinon ils peuvent pas les
trouver puisqu'il voudront pas venir
donc mais là dedans il y a en tout cas
un travail de fond à réaliser c'est
d'avoir un système
d'autorités administratives
indépendantes reposant sur des bases
identiques sur des méthodes de
fonctionnement et de contrôle identiques
en tous cas si on continue en créer une
par an on va vraiment avoir de plus en
plus de problèmes
et alors qu'est ce que vous allez
proposer vous allez vous faire un
rapport et ce rapport vous allez laisser
ce rapport c'est le rapport d'une
commission et d'anglais à une
proposition de loi où je n'ai pas
l'habitude de travailler simplement pour
dans le but d'occuper un certain nombre
d'après-midi aux matinées de
parlementaires donc ce rapport il sera
suivi de propositions de loi que je
déposerai suppression de certaines oui
mais le gars comme si je vous soumets
l'autorité de contrôle des nuisances
aéroportuaires bonithon la suppression
nous il nous dit l'accès aux documents
administratifs
la commission d'accès aux documents
administratifs on en a besoin alors
qu'elles soient regroupées qu'elles
soient regroupées peut-être avec le
défenseur des droits peut se concevoir
mais celle là on en a besoin
il y en a dont l'utilité quand même pose
pose question tout cela vous savez nous
avons auditionné le notre ancien
collègue le doyen gélard qui a travaillé
là dessus et qui nous a dit et moi je
pense qu'il faut en supprimer 80 %
marine est la question
donc soit par suppression soit par
regroupements mais en tout cas il ya un
message fort du parlement qui est à
exprimer c'est qu'on peut pas continuer
à en créer une par an et on ne peut pas
continuer à accepter que l'état se
désengage d'un certain nombre de
responsabilités en dix ans et plus -
c'est une autorité administrative
indépendante
on a vu pour le ca ca 20 que finalement
les conditions de désignation de la
présidente et de france télécom poser au
moins autant de problèmes que quand
c'était le précédent président de la
république qui désignèrent donc ça
laisse à réfléchir à ce que vous dites
c'est qu'on pourrait supprimer le csa
que le pas dit ça non non on a beau on a
besoin d'une structure est un qui ne
suis pas être soumises à la suspicion on
a besoin effectivement d'une structure
dont on considère qu'elle est verte
ta ble ment indépendante et dont les
modes de fonctionnement et de
désignation ne donne pas lieu à ce qui
est en train de se passer
d'accord notamment des recours tout à
fait mais est-ce que vous ratez pas un
peu votre cible parce qu'à côté de ces
communes de ces autorités
administratives indépendantes qui a
aussi toute une série de commissions
administratives là on a par exemple
madame pellerin qui vient de créer un
haut conseil de la photographie monsieur
prévost vous avez parfaitement raison
mais déjà auditionné 42 autorités
administratives indépendantes dans le
cadre d'une commission enquête c'est pas
mal et moi si vous voulez mon avis là
dessus je vous le donne et si vous me
posez la question c'est que vous le
souhaitez mon avis j'en ai assez je le
dis constamment de la création de haute
autorité dans tous les domaines 1
c'est absolument invraisemblable
inacceptable nous avons quand même
réussi ce matin à la commission mixte
paritaire sur la loi notre de réforme
territoriale a supprimé le haut quand le
projet de hauts conseillers les
territoires mais il faut arrêter mais on
a l'impression aujourd'hui que chaque
ministre vos cheveux sont au conseil il
faut dire quand on ensuite on y met des
représentants dedans on peut faire
plaisir à pas mal de gens mais c'est pas
comme ça qu'on peut faire avancer
l'administration française et les
installeurs alors la loi notre justement
c'est une simplification administrative
là au niveau des collectivités pour vous
nous il faut tout est à refaire il faut
refaire il faudra recommencer
je crois que les élus locaux en ont
assez de la noce ferry théorie de ces
réformes qui n'arrêtent pas parce que la
réforme c'est bien si c'est mieux
qu'avant mais en tout cas si c'est la
réforme en continu je peux vous dire que
les élus locaux
moi je cumule je suis fier de cumuler
une fonction parlementaire et une
présidence de communauté d'agglomération
je peux vous dire que les élus locaux la
réforme territoriale ils en ont jusque
là ils disent stop stop stop
maintenant il avant si elle n'est pas
parfaite il sera bien on sera bien
obligé dans l'avenir de corriger c'est
un certain nombre d'effets fait à la
fusion de l'auvergne l'aed rhône alpes
dont je ne me suis pas fait mais la loi
est la loi
bon je n'y suis pas fait parce que c'est
absurde on reviendra pas en arrière ça
vous savez
c'est vous qui le dites quand il ya des
décisions absurdes qui sont faites
il est quand même possible d'envisager
que dans l'avenir on modifiera certains
errements parce que vous m'expliquerez
comment on peut fonctionner quand on est
à onze heures aller retour par le train
ou neuf heures aller-retour par par la
route de la métropole régionale si ces
salles à la recherche de la proximité on
peut faire mieux
il ya manifestement un mépris d'un
certain nombre de territoires ruraux qui
est la caractéristique de ces décisions
je n'ose pas dire à caractère francilien
mais bon je suis alors au sujet des
régions note comme les élections
régionales en décembre qui sont redoutés
par le pouvoir qui n'a depuis depuis de
2012 qui ne subit que dès que des échecs
vous craignez un nouveau un nouvel effet
qu un nouvel effet de balancier avec une
percée du front national
et ce qui ce qui se passe depuis deux
ans est l'illustration de conséquences
de certains choix qui ne nous ont pas
paru à nos opportun nous l'avons dit sur
les institutions sur la réforme
territoriales il y a manifestement aussi
des systèmes électoraux qui favorise
l'expression des populismes vous savez
faire voter nos concitoyens sur les
élections européennes dans des
circonscriptions qui n'ont aucun sens ce
qui fait qu ensuite il ne voit jamais un
député européen sur le terrain qu'il n'y
a jamais un débat dans nos départements
sur les programmes européens qu'on les
voit une fois quand ils sont en campagne
électorale et plus ensuite
et ce qui va se passer pour les
régionales c'est un peu la même chose
nous allons avoir des candidats choisis
par les parties et qui sont pas tous
mais quand même phrase
vous savez les conseils régionaux et le
scrutin malheureusement n'a pas été
changées sur nos territoires presque
personne ne les connaît voilà la réalité
on connaît les maires on connaît les
présidents d'intercommunalités on
connaît les députés les sénateurs on
connaît pas les conseillers régionaux
donc il faut pas s'étonner ensuite que
ça donne les gens connaissent sûrement
le président de religion où il compte
celui qui va être tête de liste vous
devez vous espérez encore vous une tête
de liste aux régionales comme radical de
gauche apparemment en midi pyrénées
languedoc roussillon s'est aussi plié ce
sera ce ne sera pas ses nuits à
pittsburgh - lebron belga pour moi ce
n'est pas un espoir c'est une nécessité
on ne peut pas considérer quand nous
avons des ministres au gouvernement sur
la loi macron et sur d'autres textes moi
je vote le budget considère que
l'opposition n'a pas tellement présenté
deux de meilleures solutions au niveau
budgétaire et financier nous sommes pas
d'accord sur un certain nombre de textes
mais considéré que le seul allié le seul
allié du gouvernement du parti
socialiste les radicaux de gauche et
bien sont marginalisés par le parti
socialiste ce n'est pas acceptable
ce n'est pas acceptable que vous allez
faire parce que là vous n'avez pas de
têtes de liste et fier coûté il est
possible tout à fait possible qu'il y
ait une liste radicale de gauche en
midi-pyrénées languedoc-roussillon si
aucun accord n'est possible
c'est tout bon je crois qu'il faut dire
les choses très clairement
comme madame pinel quitterait
gouvernement pour prendre sa propre tête
de liste à elle alors ils collègues
écoutez madame pinel ministre madame
delga est certainement quelqu'un de très
respectables mais je crois que il n'y
avait pas de raison que sylvia pinel
s'incline donc ce sont ce sont des
discussions entre les deux parties moi
je ne participe pas à ces discussions
mais je considère effectivement qu'il
faut savoir ce que le parti socialiste
s'il ne veut avoir à voir sur
l'hégémonie il ne veut s'il ne veut pas
voir que des supplétifs libre à lui moi
je mène en tout cas comme président de
groupe au sénat une politique de liberté
en étant clair sur les choix que le rds
fait il n'y a pas que des radicaux dans
le jeu mais bien mal récompensée je ne
cherche aucune récompense lui disent
qu'ils assument ils assument leur
comportement par rapport à tous leurs
alliés
ce qui fait que en se conduisant de
cette manière eh bien ils filent et il
se retrouve petit à petit tout seul
à suivre donc notamment dans la région
midi pyrénées languedoc roussillon
merci jean louis perrine tarneaud arrive
maintenant pour aborder d'autres sujets
dont certains sont au coeur je le disais
tout à l'heure de l'engagement des
radicaux la laïcité
quentin calmet menus des cantines
scolaires crèches au sein d'une
administration publique ou encore
ramadan fêté par la mairie de paris
à intervalles réguliers des
questionnements autour de la laïcité
reviennent au coeur du débat politique
dernière initiative au parlement sur le
sujet un texte des radicaux de gauche
après la sphère de la crèche baby loup
une loi adoptée mais aux effets minimes
elle impose la neutralité religieuse
dans les crèches privées des retouches
de la loi de 1905 auquel l'observatoire
de la laïcité n'était pas favorable
il y avait un problème puisque là cette
proposition doit imposer une totale
neutralité
absolue et générale pour tous pour toute
personne travaillant non c'est dans ces
structures c'est à dire qu'il faut
appliquer et faire respecter la laïcité
tout court sans adjectiv et c'est la
laïcité telle qu'elle a été définie par
les pères fondateurs dans tous les
partis politiques de gauche le débat est
relancé notamment depuis les attentats
de janvier à paris dernier exemple en
date la proposition de bernard cazeneuve
de former des imams au sein d'un cursus
universitaire une idée finalement
abandonnée lors du dernier congrès
socialiste pour l'ancien secrétaire
national à la laïcité du parti
socialiste il y à bien une défaillance
de nombre d'élus sur le sujet le parti
socialiste et la gauche en général n'a
pas réussi à créer un discours solide a
créé un discours alternatif pour ce
voile à se positionner de façon claire
de façon républicaine sur la question de
la laïcité et aujourd'hui il ya une
espèce de deal un peu malsain entre
certains élus locaux et les
communautarismes religieux pour
non plus faire ce travail laïque mais
échanges et politiquement
des petits services entre amis autre
reproche adressé aux politiques par la
ligue des droits de l'homme
la laïcité est souvent instrumentalisée
par le personnel politique pour
discriminer davantage que pour inclure
pour une organisation de défense des
droits de l'homme l'instrumentalisation
de la laïcité comme moyen de débat
politique non pas sur des questions de
principes de la république
mais comme une espèce de d'armes
utilisées pour dénoncer l'autre pour le
discriminé c'est quelque chose de grave
ici enjeu des prochains mois éclaircir
la position de chacun sur le sujet car
un parti est en embuscade sur ce thème
le front national voilà sur ces
questions perrine tarneaud bonsoir
désolé est ce que vous estimez jacques
mézard qu'aujourd'hui la laïcité est en
danger oui bien sûr et notamment remise
en cause par certains partis politiques
on voit que certains c'est une gauche
une certaine dérive au thon la laïcité
bien sûr je disais tout à l'heure qu'il
y avait des lignes de fracture
fondamental à l'intérieur des grands
partis sur ce sujet là nous ne l'avons
pas de fracture chez nous car nous nous
je peux dire nous sommes le parti de la
laïcité c'est un élément fondateur de
notre vie politique de tout ce que nous
avons fait depuis que nous existons et
ce qui me fait mal moi qui suis
profondément laïque c'est de voir
reprendre l'idée de la laïcité par les
extrêmes
ça c'est ces deux aussi en partie de
notre responsabilité est ce que les
grands partis politiques français l'ont
abandonné notamment parti socialiste
tout à fait mais nous aussi nous n'avons
pas été suffisamment fort nous ne sommes
pas suffisamment fait entendre depuis
des années alors que nous nous avons la
conviction que la laïcité à la française
est quelque chose d'essentiel et encore
plus aujourd'hui et que le principe en
est simple 1 c'est la religion c'est
dans la sphère privée et qu'elle n'a pas
à intervenir dans la sphère publique est
ce qu'il faut pour autant revoir la loi
de 1905
la séparation entre l'église et l'état
non parce qu'il ya beaucoup de voix
tout à fait mais là ce serait une erreur
fondamentale la loi de 1905
on va pas refaire la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen c'est un
texte fondateur
il n'y a pas de raison qu'on refasse la
loi de 1905 qui a été un élément fort du
ciment national mais il ya quand même
des mères qui exprime un certain malaise
notamment dans le financement des cultes
sinon c'est par exemple la construction
de mosquées il ya des maires des élus
par exemple de banlieue parisienne qui
sont un petit peu obligé de biaiser de
construire des salles polyvalentes qui
ensuite deviennent des lieux de culte
que vous l'aurez qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez comment les aider mais écoutez
là il ya des principes et ben si je moi
je suis de ceux qui considèrent que les
communes n'ont pas à financer des lieux
de culte et en même temps on dit qu'il
faut contrôler financement des imams
oui mais ça c'est l'argument numéro un
pour dire merci voilà si calme oui mais
enfin c'est l'argument numéro un et si
on lâche là dessus eh bien on lâchera
surtout à venir dire je je vais moi
maire d'une commune financer la
construction d'une mosquée ou d'un
temple ou de tout ce que tout ce que
l'on peut faire en matière religieuse
parce que si je ne le fais pas le qatar
le ferai écoutez on est dans un pays un
qui doit être ferme sur des règles qui
sont fondamentales parce que si on y met
si on commence à y mettre petit doigt et
moi je n'ai strictement rien contre la
religion musulmane c'est à dire que
c'est la multiplication alors la
revendication de revendication et pas
forcément simplement des musulmans il ya
un principe laïc il faut s'y tenir moins
que chacun que chacun puisse exercer
leur religion qu'il veut dans la plus
totale liberté
c'est parfait mais dans la sphère privée
on avait un socialisme dans le sujet là
qu'il parlait déjà de petits
arrangements entre amis
concrètement il pensait à quoi je n'ai
certains élus 7 face aux poussées
communautariste
je comprends que dans certaines communes
dans certaines communes où le poids
électoral de certaines communautés et
fort il y à des élus qui ont tendance à
ne pas résister à ses tunes c'est
évident mais je ne crois pas que ce soit
une bonne à ce camp par exemple à la
nuit du ramadan quand on évoquait un
instant à paris à l'hôtel de ville
je peux pas vous dire que je trouve que
la nuit du ramadan à paris soit une
bonne idée
elle doit elle devrait rendre sa cet
événement qui est organisé plusieurs
années voilà l'idée legault vous me
posez la question je considère que ce
n'est pas une bonne chose
bon alors ensuite je n'ai pas à juger du
côté électoralistes ou d'un
électoralistes moi je me situe au niveau
des principes
parce que ce sera sans fin dans le dans
le xiiie arrondissement
nous avons beaucoup de nos concitoyens
qui sont d'origine chinoise alors on va
prendre leurs traditions il faut pas les
empêcher de respecter leurs propres
traditions mais là le public
la collectivité n'a pas à intervenir là
dedans votre réaction à l'appel lancé
par deux mythes l'imac touche pas à mon
église contre la transformation des
églises en mosquée c'est peut-être le
cas dans le cantal cantal non non je
désire répéter il y en a évidemment j'ai
l'habitude de ne signer aucune pétition
donc je comprends et je crois qu'il ne
faut pas provoquer dans concitoyens il y
a un attachement tout à fait clair de
chez nombre de nos concitoyens à des
traditions les églises dont quand même
un fond comme on dit un de pays chrétien
menez quand elles sont désertés par les
français écoutez je crois que je crois
qu'il faut être réaliste c'est quelque
chose qui sera très mal vécu 6 6 dans un
secteur la communauté catholique par
exemple considère que c'est une bonne
chose ça peut se faire mais le faire de
manière provocatrice
il ne faut provoquer personne ni les
catholiques ni les musulmans ni les
protestants ils vous disent il faut les
respecter et quand on prend des mesures
qui sont de nature justement à les
provoquer
ce n'est pas une bonne chose il un
rapport rendu hier au sénat d'une
commission d' enquête sur l'école et les
valeurs républicaines qui t a notamment
présidé par une sénatrice radicale
françoise laborde une vingtaine de
propositions qui vont du rap
rétablissement de l'uniforme à l'école à
la suppression des allocations en cas
d'absentéisme au brouillage des
téléphones à la suppression des
tablettes c'est un peu troisième
république non tous à m'écouter et
qu'avez vous contre la troisième arme
unique
elle a beaucoup fait pour la france elle
a amené beaucoup sur le territoire
national elle a amené l'école partout
elle a amené le train partout elle a
amené le téléphone partout et si toutes
les républiques était aussi efficace que
la troisième république l'a dit et ça se
saurait donc donné le sens républicaine
alors dansez dansez mesure j'ai lu les
verts mesure je ne les partage pas tout
le fait de créer des lits raid et des
maisons spécialisées pour ceux qui remue
trop me paraît pas être une idée géniale
mais globalement ce sont essentiellement
des mesures de bon sens ce sont des
mesures visant à restaurer l'école la
laïcité
l'idée de la république à l'école il n'y
a pas grand chose là dedans je vous le
dis enfin je le dis que qui me choque
yalu
l'école d'enseigner les valeurs
républicaines bien sûr bien sûr c'est à
républicaines
bien sûr que c'est à l'école de faire ce
qu'on appelait l'éducation civique et si
l'école il est franc que l'école d'abord
elle doit apprendre à lire à écrire
français les mathématiques l'histoire
c'est pas tout je sais pas toujours le
cas aujourd'hui
et puis elle doit être l'école de la
république c'est en tout cas la vision
qui est la nôtre depuis que nous
existons depuis effectivement la
troisième république à dire qu'il ya un
consensus sur ce que vous dites là côté
jeu je crois qu'il y à un large
consensus si long feu si l'on consulté
nos concitoyens sur ces vingt mesures il
y en aurait peut-être une ou deux ou
trois qui poserait problème est très
largement
ça correspond aujourd'hui à un sentiment
république et qu'il soit porté par un
rapporteur ump avec une présidente de
commission radical moi ça ne me choque
pas au contraire on entend beaucoup
jacques mézard actuellement notamment
dans la bouche de l'exécutif et dans
celle de françois hollande que la
procédure parlementaire est trop lente
ça va pas assez vite est ce que vous
êtes d'accord si ça va pas assez vite le
premier responsable en et l'exécutif
parce que à force d'accumuler les
projets de loi pour montrer qu'on essaie
de tout réformer parce qu'avant c'était
pas assez bien et que ça sera mieux
demain
si l'exécutif le président de la
république pour les ministes arrêter de
nous envoyer des projets de loi qui sont
épais plusieurs dizaines de pages avec
des centaines d'articles la loi
maquereau en est un exemple la
transition énergétique en est un exemple
la loi santé en est un exemple
la réforme territoriale en est un
exemple je venais texte tout à fait
parce que une bonne loi c'est une loi
courte ce n'est pas une loi bavarde
évidemment quand vous apporter 200
articles et des amendements
c'est très bien
la sauce bien sûr qu'on rallonge la
sauce que c'est naturel quand vous avez
200 articles vous discutez c'est
automatique vous présenter les
amendements sur cet article
si on nous apporte un texte de loi où il
ya un deux trois articles vous verrez
qu'il y aura moins d'amendements le nous
sommes dans un système qui est à bout de
course par rapport à ça mais la
responsabilité de la durée de la loi
elle elle incombe d'abord à l'exécutif à
bout de course ça veut dire qu'il va y
avoir des réformes institutionnelles
alors est ce que vous craignez que sous
cette petite musique ambiante un de
procédures parlementaires trop lente
c'est le bicamérisme qu'ils pourraient
être visés menacée nous savons bien nous
avons entendu les propos du président de
l'assemblée nationale monsieur bartolone
il n'aime pas le sénat il veut le
supprimer c'est d'ailleurs dans good ou
drella bientôt quitter l'assemblée pour
faire campagne
et oui il était il était à fond pour le
non cumul
donc il nous démontre en étant à la fois
président de l'assemblée nationale et
candidat pour être président de région
que entre le discours et l'action pour
un certain nombre des responsables
politiques il ya une grande nuance oui
françois hollande pourrait convoquer un
congrès en 2016 début 2016 pour
notamment faire ratifier la charte sur
les langues régionales est ce que vous
voterez pour le texte arrive au sénat à
l'automne
à titre personnel non et c'est pas la
position de notre groupe
côté livres chacun est libre c'est une
caractéristique
ça veut dire si vous déjà vous voté
contre y perd des voix à gauche et donc
il a du mal à avoir une majorité
c'est une position près personne parce
que vous êtes contre l'idée est que l'on
valorise les langues régionales au
détriment
je crois que je vous en avais l'unicité
de la république la langue nationale
oui je je je le concède - qui est qu'on
puisse enseigner des langues régionales
qu'il y ait des moyens apportés par
certaines collectivités 1 pour les
langues régionales ça ne me choque pas
mais aujourd'hui où on voit un que
l'apprentissage de la langue
l'apprentissage du français pose
tellement de problèmes
est ce que c'est vraiment aujourd'hui
qu'il faut se lancer là dedans je ne
crois pas donc vous le conseillez pas
faire de contre et là dessus il faut
franchement ils me demandent rarement
conseille même jamais je ne me
permettrais jamais eu tout du tout ils
pourront consulter quand même les
radicaux de gauche
je ne doute pas qu'il consulte le
président du parti radical de gauche
mais je suis le président du rda se
s'est dit fier merci jacques mézard
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui s'il
ya faute merci louis n'allez vous
soigner j'y cours à trévé que je m'en
sors à tous